all right little buddy come on
hello my little darling
oh man [ __ ] you
you [ __ ] my
this health thing
okay buddy take it easy
nothing ever been easy for me in my life
to hook me up with a treat
she does talk like you're listening yeah
oh my gosh last time i was like who are
you you're brilliant i know shut up
oh my god oh my god
oh my god amy look at that one
nicely it's so cute that is the cutest
effing puppy i've ever seen my entire
life oh my god i'm just gonna take him
and i just want to bite his little ears
off i just want to take his little legs
and just like slack on them like little
like like chicken drummettes yeah i just
want to take his fuzzy little perfect
head i want to put it in my mouth and
squeeze down on it hard until i have a
puppy face diamond
i feel like i have to wrap his face in a
towel and then beat it with a tire iron
i'm going to buy that dog i'm going to
drive him to the vet and i'm going to
have him put down me immediately look at
him oh my god you know what i'm gonna
have to do i'm gonna have to take that
scrubby little nose yeah and just kick
it i just have to i wouldn't i would
kick it until it comes off on my shoes
like little puppy snout slippers and i'm
gonna go to a party and it's like oh my
god where'd you get those slippers like
these these are my face slippers my
adorable dumb little puppy that's
exactly what i was going to say
oh my god i just want to take his head i
want to peel the skin off of his skull i
know where you're going i want to start
throwing it up like pizza dough until
it's long flat and round and i want to
take it to a picnic and toss it around
like a frisbee and a puppy face frisbee
picnic
so cute so cute
oh my god is it me or is it like totally
mosquitoey out here oh my god remember
this one he was so cute
i want a place jamie is not english he's
not i don't know what nationality is but
he's definitely not that's amazing
i'm so sorry
i just rescued him from a shelter
he seems to get really aggressive
towards people with darker color skin
i'm so sorry
don't worry about it yeah i guess you
never know what they've been through
before you get them we don't think that
your dog's racist
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
hey babe hi
um i made a really big decision without
consulting you
i i went by um
a puppy rescue stand on university
avenue
i had to i had to
you got us a dog yeah i did
so honey i've got to tell you something
okay
these rescue dogs have had some tough
situations
and a lot of them take on the
personality of their owners
this dog
was owned by rapper ice
all
tea
little buddy come on
hello my little darling
oh man [ __ ] you
you [ __ ] my
this house thing
okay buddy take it easy
nothing ever been easy for me in my life
hook me up with a treat you want a treat
buddy you want a treat is that what you
want here
um yeah that's a tasty ass treat right
there now give me the whole bag okay one
treat is enough [ __ ] without talking to
you
give me the whole bag of treats cause
i'm a treat killer and a [ __ ]
somebody's grumpy today
grumpy whoopee
lay my ass right up on this comfortable
ass sofa
i'm gonna sleep on this [ __ ] too as a
matter of fact you know what
[ __ ] and [ __ ] i'm epiphan up
here too no oh no no no
raise your hand at me okay um i've got
something for you little guy
huh huh you want to play fetch you want
to play fetch you like fetch get that
ball
you both your defending mother i ain't
your entertainment [ __ ] so [ __ ] you
hello who is this
come on coco don't worry about these
fats my [ __ ] coco well if i got to tell
y'all she's gonna be living here too wow
okay you got your little friend here
yeah yeah well you can uh she could play
here for a while sure puppy playdate
yeah playdate we gonna have a date we
gonna have [ __ ]
come here [ __ ]
yeah oh he's right are you just doing
that oh no don't do that oh yeah that's
my [ __ ] suit okay oh dear get the [ __ ]
out of here it's about to get graphic in
this [ __ ]
how come you don't do that with me honey
i told you he does it i just want to
keep this area clean brock favors here
filling in for chad armstrong who is out
sick today
we are here live at the metro police
department k9 training facility and we
are going to be learning some
apprehension techniques used by the k9
unit now officer hanson uh i will be
playing the assailant today is that
correct yeah that's correct now officer
hanson i am perfectly safe in this suit
right yeah you're 100 safe in fact those
are the suits we use for officer
training all right well there you go
well kids make sure that you do not try
this at home with your children
whoa
okey dokey
i am sorry
that uh you all just uh
heard me use that inappropriate language
that was very uncalled for when you
panic like that yeah he thinks you're
more of a threat than you are that's
when he's gonna bite down harder
okay well i will make an effort this
time to
really try and
be as calm as possible even though it is
very difficult to be calm when you're in
the lion's den or should i say the dog
you're dead
he's here he's here come on baby come on
get your sign brandon bring the camera
come on let's go
hold it out
hold on right for daddy so daddy can see
there
my god i love you so much rock oh hey
let's go come on
good job good dog there we go oh i
missed you so much
where is he
stanley oh
what's going on oh come on i know you've
been cheating on me you're being
ridiculous andrea
enough is enough i know you have been
a dog behind my back
what
a dog a dog that is insane then why did
i find this in the laundry room
oh my god
he's here right now isn't he he's in my
house right now
stanley no wait
oh
oh
oh
i see
you
need to know
your dog ruined a 10-year marriage
and you
can go to hell
he's cute he's cute i can see why you
like him
[Music]
come
you're big you're big
[Music]
[Music]
no hey what are you eating what are you
get the [ __ ] away from me oh but that's
food golf that's food though
[Music]
i like that
i like the way you look
looking good to me
[Music]
you a dude sorry that's okay it happens
[Music]
hey what's up there listen is there
something up there yes is it up there
yes hey come here i want to eat your
mouth you are going to eat you in my
mouth
[Music]